si on se retrouve en zone à
ensuite on se retrouve en zone b tout
jusqu'à pratiquement roscanvel un
littoral divisé en zones autorisées ou
non à la pêche à pied voilà ce qui
provoque la colère des finistériens
d'autant qu'ici le tiers de la côte
serait interdite une véritable remise en
cause d'un certain arquette faut un
breton allez à là la grande marée c'est
un peu comme aller à la grand-messe
c'est pareil on va communier avec la mer
ça c'est un rite c'est c'est comme ça ad
la réglementation européenne impose le
classement des zones conchylicoles s'il
concerne d'abord les professionnels il
est plus contraignant pour les
ramasseurs du dimanche pour eux seuls
les coquillages de la zone à sont jugés
comme estime favorables et chaque fois
déjà se renseigner si l'endroit où on va
ne présente pas de risque sur le plan de
la consommation
autrement je vois pas pourquoi on
interdit encore une chose qui devrait
être laissé au bon sens des gens on a
bouffé les unes ou depuis des années des
avions et emma une fois notamment pour
les pêcheurs à pied ce classement est
aussi le constat d'échec de la lutte
contre la pollution
c'est sur la qualité de l'eau qu'il faut
d'abord agir il va falloir que les
pouvoirs publics prennent quand même
conscience de cette chose là elle se
contente pas d'interdire parce que ça ne
résoudra pas les problèmes
ultime inquiétudes réduites de 30% les
zones de pêche subiront davantage la
pression des amateurs rapidement ils
risquent de ne plus rester grand chose à
pêcher